today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza it's
uh it's exactly what it is man it's a
pizza
he knew that gray block 18:11 Pico
Boulevard in Los Angeles on the way to
the beach grey block in today's episode
is brought to you by me undies if you
want to support this past weekend and
your crotch is feeling kind of unkempt
then instead of trimming down that bad
little badger you got down there
why don't you just get in a nice pair of
meat undies me undies are made from
Modell which is three times more softer
than cotton take care of your junk and
treat yourself well go to me undies
dot-com slash weekend to get a 15% off
the individual pairs that you get so go
to meet undies dot-com slash weekend to
get that 15 percent off hitter gang gang
today's episode is also brought to you
by Ridge wallet you know a wallet is
something that's been with me with man
for a long time you know a lot of times
even if they find caveman's bodies or
something like that um they'll have a
little bag of money near their butt
cheek or by their cossacks bone and that
just shows you right there that man has
always kept things on him things of
value well the time of having that rear
that rear back wallet is over it's time
for that front pocket carry the ridge
wallet is a front pocket carry that
keeps your money and keeps your credit
cards and important documents quick
carry and all them extras bar it's and
you know maybe you might have a little
packet a jam or jelly you got from a
burger came one time you're saving it
don't carry that just carry your Ridge
wallet go to Ridge wallet comm slash
Theo and use code Theo at checkout for
10% off that's Ridge wallet comm slash
Theo and use code Theo for 10% off and
now I want to introduce you guys a guest
that you know I'm I've looked up to this
guy even though I've you know we know
each other but you know we know each
other kind of like a lot a lot in
passing but he's kind of like he's a man
that I really look up to and obviously
I'd give anything to have a career like
his
he's worked so hard and he's a true
entertainer you know you know I
personally I'm tired of joke writers
standing on stage and and call
themselves comedians I'm ready for
entertainment because that's what people
pay for and this man gives you your
money's worth every single time I'm so
honored
he's my Michael Jackson you know I'm
from his countless specials on Showtime
and Netflix he's performed at Madison
Square Gardens dude probably the most
famous Gardens since Marvin gardens or
mr. McGregor's Gardens ladies and
gentlemen it is uh it is mr. Sebastian
Maniscalco
[Music]
you know I can't even imagine how nice
it is hey y'all Evan I need the money
you buy a probably tomato farms and
stuff what do you buy
Nick was a premature baby so he never
he's got a lot of congenital issues you
know he doesn't know the little isn't it
our producer Nick know that I have a
huge insurance policies used to work at
Bronson's comedy club did you really
know he did
oh yeah Nick did huh yeah it's on back
in the day oh wow oh yeah you told me
worked there for one week and they had
two great comedians that came through
who were they Sebastian and Jay Larson
Wow yeah someone someone jumped off it's
on them have you ever been there yeah
yeah yeah so it's unlike the third level
looks over into an atrium so the day I
was performing there I walked in on a
Thursday night so I'm gonna jump off and
committed suicide and right before the
show with the line of people waiting to
get in so it's a nice start dude I got
caught up there they had a mean that's
crazy at a mall go outdoors you like
yeah maybe the parking garage yeah I
have some respect for the shoppers for
your fellow shoppers right right in the
middle where they have a Santa Claus set
up oh so so this is nice I like the
setup here man
who did this Brady Matthews on if you
know Brady's young community does a lot
of impressions he did this a Chris
Farley this isn't Mayor Donald Trump
this is Chris Farley okay uh Monica
Farley fan um yeah yeah yeah mcruiz
Farley fan I uh I remember I sat behind
his brother Kevin at the MTV Movie
Awards or something a while back and got
to sit next to Tim Arnold no Tim who was
in Shawshank Redemption Oh Tim Robinson
Tim Robbins yeah and it was crazy I was
from her tapping his brother on the
shoulder and be like man I'm so sorry
about your brother
and his brother looking like shut the
[ __ ] up dude you don't know but now I
know Kevin and it's nice but yeah I love
Chris Farley he ever worked with him I
never did Chris Farley I was a huge fan
of his and never never met him never
crossed paths I think he kind of passed
away prior to me getting into the
entertainment business so yeah dude so
how much you must have crazy money now
you got money and you're Italian so you
probably have like your baby hiding it
around the house and stuff I bet you cuz
I watched your Instagram videos man
they're they're great it's nice to see
you at the family and everything and you
you know being able to achieve a lot of
your dreams and stuff but I bet Loki you
guys are doing some crazy stuff at night
around there hiding cash under the floor
and stuff well if you know anything
about Italians we don't talk so but
things are good I really enjoyed my
family and yeah man it's been really
really nice too and we've talked over
the years in regards to like keep this
business yeah how you you know break
through and whatnot so it's it's been a
long long road but after 20 years
finally starting to kind of peek my head
out of the ground and yeah I'm getting
some fans so how do they ground at the
bank bro I don't know if you know this
is a financial show look Sebastian
you've never seen like a money guy I'm
just gay I'm just excited for you I
guess it is is it weird when like if you
don't come from money and stuff and pee
is it it's it's weird to start having
money isn't it
well grew up in a middle-class family
northwest suburbs of Chicago and you
know we didn't we didn't have a lot of
money by any means you know my dad was a
beautician my mother was a secretary and
you know we went on vacation once a year
and you know had two cars it was it was
it was a nice nice bring up yeah like
the Wonder you sound like that Fred
Savage kind of one day years kind of
stop exactly exactly and now yeah I mean
it listen I'm not a guy who buys a lot
of stuff I'm not a car guy I mean
I'm not a I mean I like clothes and I
like actually sharing this success with
my family right my father my mother oh
wow you know we went out to Italy you
know what you know what I'm gonna have
to do yeah and I'd typically don't do
this I gotta take off the podcast Jack
it's gonna hold is it really
well hang it up for you I'm gonna get up
and hanging up okay cuz I'm getting
heated talking about you money and yes
Sebastian you can really pull that over
so you're speaking right down the barrel
cuz you got that cool sultry voice yeah
I know it's my music voice oh man and I
put on a nice vest for you that's very
nice it's it's basic no you look well
put together I mean we do when I used to
party and a lot of our mothers notice I
used to you know get a little bit of
drugs and I would you know I had a vest
I would I bought I probably bought about
$6,000 worth of s bra vests yeah you
wanted a vest Oh spree I'm that armless
adventure baby out there
do you ever hug somebody in a vest
rubbing nothing else on I have I got
into a bus the original honey that's a
Greek honeymoon you're right a vest but
no I would spend that's what I spent my
money on in vests yeah over time now as
I get older this I like I collect you
know some people collect you might
collect nice jackets you know you know
some people are shoe guys like that's
one thing I would just be like I had
vast like for some reason I got into it
about eight years ago and I've had a
collection over the years so are you
still whipping out those of us not as
much I would do drugs at night by myself
at home and put them all on bra you
would put a vest on to do drugs not do
the drugs first that thing let's go
after the vest for a bi-product I think
it sound my behaviors all right but what
was something yeah we you were talking
about spending some spending some
caching you like spitting on your family
and my family
I took my sister her family and my
mother to Italy this year and we enjoyed
Tuscany together so that's what I like
to do I like to kind of share
and because these people been with me
you know for the last 20 years they've
come to every show right they've been
very supportive and it's very very I'm
really into family and now that I have a
little daughter and my wife that's kind
of where my my heart is is my family's
yeah and that's why I talk about my in
my act not only my family but my father
and the whole Italian upbringing that oh
yeah yeah it's nice it's finally nice I
mean after you know I was selling
satellite dishes in the mall and a
ghetto at one point dad to you know get
by at the $10,000 worth the BET so it
was it was a struggle as you well know
you know and and now I'm very grateful
that everything is kind of working out
even or now it's interesting it's almost
do you feel like in some ways like it's
like it's evening out because what's
interesting is you don't for me anyway I
don't remember almost all the times that
I put in that were not valueless but
definitely we're not a lot of like
fiscal reward at all like all the
weekends of flying like you said you win
$10,000 in debt same here I think I went
like I think I had honestly once I was
all said and done almost 20 20 something
on credit cards just from you know you
either paid $600 to fly to Buffalo for
the weekend as a feature you come back
you lost 400 you know yeah that gets
just an investment yes but all that kind
of goes into the past as you start to
like you forget about it a little bit
like I guess it feels like it evens out
a little bit well I think we were
compensated probably for all this times
that we didn't get paid so you know
right making up for that but I'm well
aware of those times where it was I live
in the negative so I'm always you know
things are good now but I'm always
waiting you know for that time when
people don't come to the show oh yeah
I'm never like these positive guys that
you see up on an Instagram like a Gary
Vee or to rock or whatnot Mark Wahlberg
that whole thing like hey man you got to
get up at 4:00 I'm not that guy I'm the
guy who is you know I'm waiting to fall
off the mountain right climb up it
yeah and that's what kind of keeps me
Mom
yeah yeah like you're paying it like
you're talking to the trash guy like
look just let me know into some openings
over there like you're playing in a head
well that's a family I'm from you know
they're very kind of like negative
people yeah and that's kind of how I am
I mean I try to be positive don't get me
wrong but I live in fear
yeah wow that's that's that's what keeps
me going
did we have a question actually oh I
wonder does even start the podcast off
with this but podcasts start where they
start Sebastian Maniscalco is here today
in huge fans so happy to have you here
bro thank you so much over time thank
you for all you do for comedy dude I was
watching this clip the other day and we
even put it up as we get a lot of video
submissions and call submissions and it
was a goober ex it's like hitchhiking
with your phone mm-hmm and I laughed
about it yesterday and then this morning
in the shower you know not looking at my
body or anything but I laughed about it
again you know that's good that you're
thinking about who breaks out like a
good bra uberx is like hitchhiking with
your phone we had a question that came
in right here we enlisted let's go to
that Sebastian and Theo when was the
last time you cried like sobbing I
really cried because I feel like you
might have to just do any of your family
just get your point across but I want to
know like if not to bring the show down
but my daughter was in the hospital this
weekend oh that's when I ball I bawled
what is a Tuesday I bawled good really
mean a good ball son yeah and I'm a
sensitive guy yeah I I have no problem
crying yeah I mean either I'll cry I
might cry during this podcast but yeah I
cried Sunday because my daughter had a
respiratory issue and we went in and to
see your daughter and tubes and whatnot
mmm that's killer so but yeah I'm a big
crier yeah I'm the sensitive one and in
my relationship with my wife really oh
yeah movie comes on I'm like ball and I
look over I got nothing you know the
limit so like Bridges of Madison County
you ever see that I've never seen that
is that a cry
oh my god do you lose weight during your
gonna shed you better bring t-shirts
better in your home oh Bridges of
Madison County's great yeah I've never
just a love story teeka watch it with
the lady um so and now what part of it
though like you're spending time with
your daughter like was it right whenever
you like she got the sickness or was it
was something like was there a certain
thing that made you think like that
really kind of spooked you that kind of
made you tear up um well she was in
there for three days viral infection and
for me I was on the road so my wife had
to go and kind of do this all on her own
I was gonna come home and then she had
start to turn around and I'm like
alright if everything's okay I'll just
do these gigs but it was one of those
things where you know with all the shows
all the stuff that's going on when
something like that happens that's all
that matters
right the child you could throw the
career out the door the baby and you
don't have a kid do you I don't
yeah I think about it a lot though yeah
it's you know I'm 45 so I this happened
to me late in life she's a year and a
half almost so when the baby goes down
like that you could you that's all that
matters that's all that matters anyway
right then when that happens it's all
personifies it like ten times
you're like you'd really put you in
check where you know you slow down and
you go what is important this is
important and ya could cry though bro
yeah I died when I crying yeah yeah it's
where does it start it start in the face
does it start it's it's it comes from
the field it's just swell from the roots
up oh you see surfers showing up parking
outside of his house is really picking
up footage in his legs
yeah really in the hips I could see you
being something coming out of the hip
seat yeah I think it I think it
definitely affects it the hips on its
way and yeah it's a good it's a good I
think everybody needs a good cry every
once in a while just don't wash it out
oh dude
half this podcast is based on Tears this
podcast is built on brackish face water
things bad when when did you last cry
probably last episode I can almost every
other episode and here's something
brings me kind of to tears we had a
moment on this podcast where this isn't
a funny podcast also by the way so don't
feel like you have any pressure to be
funny um but it's like we had a moment
what was it you know the last time I had
a good cry bro was when like you know my
mother was a hard worker when I was
growing up and she still lives you know
my mother delivered newspapers she's
always been a delivery person and uh
like I sent her like a thousand bucks or
something a couple weeks ago you know
and she had told me that like a man
she'd worked for it was paying a really
bad and you didn't uh he was making her
do extra work that wasn't included in
the original agreement I'm on 71 now so
she's out there moving these bundles of
papers and everything and just so I was
like oh no you know here's this money
you know a man's not gonna treat my
mother like that you know and for me it
was just like like I'd never even told
my mother that or I'd never even you
know started to think as a child you
just kind of you know I guess you can
become your mom's not caretaker but you
at a certain point you're not just a son
anymore like you're kind of like a C&I
dog in a way kind of you know you know
and uh so that for me was like pretty
powerful and I'm [ __ ] crying at the
house bro you know and I've been smoking
cigarettes then I got all depressed
probably and who knows man I'll put on
an odd Oh then I go into a loop that
I'll put on Finding Neverland with
Johnny Depp
oh so you really like you're crying
you're like you just you're just trying
to get more stuff to get you go dude
yeah it's like alright this talks just I
just get into it man but that's what got
me going you know is uh was that made me
have some emotion
yeah family's important to me though did
you think that you were going to as your
career got along did you start to worry
like Oh am I gonna because at a certain
point you're all-in with comedy yeah you
know especially around 15 years I mean
you were all in I was all in the day one
oh really yeah I never thought I was
gonna do anything else I never had it
like a back-up plan I never had like hey
I'm gonna do five years and then if I
don't do it I'm gonna go back home this
was a
comedy or bust for me there was no I had
no other had no skills so I went to
college I graduated with a corporate
communications there drama yeah and I
don't really have any other skill sets
yeah I mean if I wasn't doing comedy I
think I'd be a general manager of a
five-star hotel because I like the
hospitality industry I could see that
and I was a waiter at the Four Seasons
so I really really enjoy travel yeah and
I enjoy all the nuances of travel
whether it be the airplane the customer
service oh yeah every how everything
works when it comes to travel fascinated
by it really I could see you doing like
high in like hot air balloon rides like
really high end oh I'm talking about
going in like endangered airspace um you
know Wow no I never I'm not I've done a
hot air balloon ride I'm not a big
that's a safety concern for yeah I like
to be underground Wow really a lot of
parameters there's a lot of rules with
being Sebastian Maniscalco yeah but did
you start to think like as you're
thinking okay my career is very
important to me or my career this is my
life you know it's it becomes really
your life you miss out on a lot of
things as a comedian that touring that
people don't realize did you find that
like you miss out on friends you know
different experiences yeah um I kind of
as far as friendships are concerned I
kind of I don't have a lot I don't hang
around with a lot of people yeah um a
lot of my friends are still back in
Chicago I mean I still have friends here
in LA I've that I've met over the course
of the 20 years that I've been out here
but I never felt a missing with not
being around any friendships or anything
like that it was I was so involved in
trying like like you know going
traveling every weekend coming home
unpacking getting getting back on an
airplane and doing it all over again so
I never really was concerned of what I
was missing out on because I knew in the
end whatever I missed out on I would be
able to kind of make up for it in the
success of doing stand-up comedy so you
know I've been working for 20 years and
this is the first time this year that I
took taken like a good chunk off to
really
kind of reflect enjoy have like a little
balance cuz with this business I think
you got to live life in order to draw
from it that's how I that's how I do my
comedy I don't really get my comedy
sitting on an airplane or going to a
dark room in writing I get my comedy
from going to a a preschool interview
yeah just doing just doing the regular
things of life yeah and that's if you
want to see they want to see Sebastian
going through regular life yeah that's
so fast and that's what's funny to me
yeah it's just funny to us as viewers
his listeners yeah it's just thinking
great oh you like did you hear dude
Sebastian got stuck standing in line
yeah nuances of life that's
observational type humor has been a huge
huge thing with me and I've always loved
watching other comedians talk about
real-life situation right there be
family whether it be friends going
dating whatever whatever it is I really
enjoy that those those stories opposed
to kind of made-up stories that someone
just conjured up but I could appreciate
it but I need a laugh I like I like the
pain that another comedians going
through it makes it makes me really
really laugh it adds to it yeah there's
something there's something makes you
laugh when somebody like gets hurt it
always like you know if they don't get
hurt really bad like not dead but you
know like I saw one time a guy took a
took a eight ball off of a pool table
were out on the street and he threw it
down the street dude and he hit another
dude man and it hit him like in the
thigh or something you know someplace
hit one gonna kill him you couldn't hear
it but man you heard it come out of him
it was like it made no sound hitting him
and then all the sound coming out of his
throat when he just yelled yeah I mean
physical pain is is often funny but I'm
I'm talking about like you know when I
watch you you talk about growing up and
you go into school and that environment
that you grew up in school not that it
was painful
but I I didn't grow up that way right I
don't I don't I have no experience that
I go oh that was me
but the fact that the way you tell that
story and you bring us into your world
that's where I find
as a viewer that when you could cross
that and and and bring someone who
didn't bring up grow up like you but you
could still laugh at the situation's
right those those those comedians to me
are a joy to watch I don't particularly
like the humor that's kind of fabricated
out of nowhere yeah yeah you know one
thing I think you've done for comedy and
I'm you know I feel like I'm in a little
bit of the wake of that is just bring
back like the art of an actual
entertainer because for a long time it
seems like it's been about like joke
writers but I think anybody could get up
there and do that I want to see the
person up there I want to get my money's
worth that's what I feel like and I'm
sure with a lot of your fans these guys
want to get their money's worth they
probably you know people probably trying
to buy your sweat backstage when it came
in imagine especially a lot of a Italia
min or Loki Liberace's I feel like not
the gay side but everything else you
know the flashy silks you know the extra
sweat glands I feel like they got a lot
going on yeah do you think you've hit
something on the head there where they
bring in the entertainment aspect of
especially in stand-up comedy you know
you have you know there's something to
be said about going to a show and seeing
a kind of spectacle or a guy or a woman
up there really really entertaining
exhibiting their soul yeah and I'm
trying making an effort after this
cry-baby comedy so many people just like
who are well off but they're just crying
about life it's like I'm I don't get
that man oh I feel like I'll owe it to
the people now more than ever you do you
do and and for these people to come out
and see what we do I've always I've
always looked at it as like you're
coming into my house and I'm gonna take
your shoes off number one but if you're
coming over to my house I'm going to
make sure if like I'm a big observer and
I'm looking at what you got your coffee
you got juice I don't know if you you
typically drink that but I'll make
mental notes of what really what you
like if I have a party I will make sure
that if you're a drinker and I know you
drink Jack that Jack Daniels will be
the party that's kind of how I do with
my shows like I if you're gonna come to
the show a I'm going to take care of you
with the entertainment v I always used
to go out and meet the people after the
show yeah
take photos that's where I'm at right
now for sure and if you get that
one-on-one connection with somebody
you'll have a fan for life I'm telling
you and you're doing it the right way
where you go out there and you like
you're appreciative of these people
coming out and I'm so grateful so that's
kind of what I did for the last 10 years
I was outside hanging outside comedy
clubs whether there was 12 people in the
audience or 300 I would wait till
everybody left took a picture with
everybody and I wasn't doing it I wanted
to do it number one and number two I
knew if I did do it the people would
come back and we feel like kind of like
we're making it together yeah you know
and and and my fans are the people I
would probably hang out with their
families they're like groups that come
in like packs
yeah whole neighborhood will come out
and it's great
no I it seems like it's been great man
let's take it I want to make sure we
include some of these let's take another
one of these video calls and none of
this is live either we can edit any of
this well it's just fascinating to me
because I don't do a lot of podcasts
right you impede had one for Waldi still
have it yes okay we do and it's called
the Pete Sebastian show we do it once a
week but you know the fact that you got
like video callers and and all this
fascinates me in the sense that is this
your brainchild is this did you go
listen I want to be in a room I want
this I want I want the look of it I want
the video or is this a collaboration
that you're coming up with with a group
of people I'm always right here is to
find out like how much of it is the
person that's doing this and or how much
is somebody going No yeah we're gonna do
video call and you go oh you got a video
call or did you see this somewhere else
and go we got to have that on our show
this is a great question here's what
happens so I was shooting the podcast at
home out of my kitchen you know and
because I'm polish Nicaragua don't even
if you know that we do a lot of work out
of the kitchen
and we're [ __ ] kitchen people and and
so I was shooting it there there's a
pizza the pizza place called grey block
pizza the guy hit me up he's like hey
man I love your podcast I'm gonna give
you a thousand bucks a month you know
just grandfather me out on the podcast I
want you to get out of your kitchen I
want you to get into a studio so that
gave me just enough money cuz I had
saved up like $800 from little ads and
stuff and I've been after about a year
to get into the studio and then once we
did that this was my this was like the
nicest piece art I have still have in my
life right here this is at the house was
like we got to get this in here fight
her in the kitty this was their old
studio there now through the wall right
here ruin one of Brendon's takes he's
taking some [ __ ] over there right now so
this was their old studio he got laid
off from Corolla one night for drinking
too much at a party [ __ ] pick that
dude up on the [ __ ] free agent wire
100% and with that along the way is that
fans have been here as we just struggle
with a lot of stuff and dealt with stuff
and and it's been fascinating man and
now we have like we get 2 and 1/2
million listens a month and it's
absolutely crazy bro so what was it your
what was your tipping point here where
you kind of you know really exploded and
it was it was it your comedy was that
the podcast is the podcast feeding the
people coming out to see your shows is
advice versa that you have such a big
swell of stand-up comedian fans that
they are now listening to your podcast
I'm fascinated with the podcast world
just because we're or is it the fact
that you go on Joe Rogan you pick up
that how does it work I don't know you
know I think it's a big it's a big mix I
mean the producer Nick has definitely
helped you know because he helps with
social media elements and a lot of
inspiration and he knew about podcasting
I think the you know 15 years you doing
stand-up and having the stand-up to back
it up when people have started to come
out that's where I'm at right now is
people are just starting to come out to
the shows like I just started like
selling out some places like a couple of
months ago really within the past 5
months so it's been and rogue and
definitely helped I mean undeniably he
had me on like twice within like two
months and that was like you know
that really really helped a lot inviter
and the kids been really good to me
those guys
KOCO Diaz Joey Diaz who else that's been
a lot of it and then showing up every
week for the podcast it's been you know
the fans appreciate that I think a lot
of it has come from your podcast
appearances but like just going on them
isn't what does it he goes and he
delivers they're like I got to hear more
of this guy so then they look him up
like there's a lot of people that do the
podcast circuit but they don't see the
numbers increase like he gets when he
doesn't appearance yeah they know that
better because he's a you know he knows
about the podcast because I know when I
saw you on the podcast it and also I saw
you on stage which I've never seen
before and I don't know if this is
something new that you're doing but your
way of using vocabulary and your the way
you string words together like it's it's
very unique and I was wondering myself
and this this appearance on this show is
more of a learning experience for me as
well because I to theatre that I always
really wanted to discuss this with you
is it this did this come out of nowhere
this language that you do I mean yeah
literally these these that's almost like
a stream of conscious where he's like
well how do you even pair those two
words together and it's the way you
deliver the words it's just something
that happened recently because I don't
think I've ever seen it before I know
maybe I wasn't just paying attention but
where's this where's this language
congregate no one talks like yeah I
don't know I think it lives in the back
of my neck man is it coming so coming
from your hip I just have are getting
Clint Eastwood baby I'm you know I'm not
K so in some way a bad boy you know it's
like you just don't know what can be
paired up it's just it's just it's it's
really fun to watch I mean I'm not
blowing [ __ ] up no I appreciate it and
it's it's fun to watching and I remember
watching you on you were doing Yahoo
News or an entertainment so whoever a
little bit I think oh my hair and was
falling out yeah dude I was it our the
best guy interviewed over at Yahoo was
micro remember him from Dirty Jobs yeah
dude that guy was the best he said he
tried for 12 years to sell that show
dirty job really and people told him
that
well and finally he got it and it was a
hit
excuse me guys I know well we were
learning Italian there from the king
himself mr. Maniscalco but I got to tell
you about something you know a lot of
people's breath stinks and a lot of
people aren't taking care of them little
bad boys in their mouths and I'm talking
about their teeth do you know that
people brush their teeth every day and
that they often do it wrong you know a
lot of times we feel like the first way
we learn to do something and we just
keep doing it that way well I used to
put my shoes on first and then my socks
and people thought I was an idiot was I
I don't know but but there's a better
way to brush your teeth is what I'm
trying to tell you and that is with quip
Q UIP
quip is a better electric toothbrush
created by dentists and designers it was
designed to make brushing your teeth
more simple affordable and even
enjoyable a lot of people they brush
their teeth too hard and they're just
great they're just beating their teeth
it's like they're just like beating a
baseball bat against a dirty Chevrolet
and that's not what you want to do you
want it you want to you want to take
care of your teeth properly and that's
equip does it has a built-in two-minute
timer that pulses every 30 seconds to
remind you when to switch sides and it D
clutters your sink or cabinet and makes
traveling with an electric toothbrush
way easier you just charge it once and
it stays for three months on one charge
no more old bristles none of that and
that's why I love quip because it's new
it's fun and it gets the job done
they're back to over 20,000 dental
professionals and it starts at just $25
so go to get quick comm slash weekend
right now and you'll get your first
refill pack for free with a quip
electric toothbrush that's right your
first refill pack free at get quip comm
slash weekend
that's GE t qu IP dot-com slash weekend
take care of your mouth to carry your
breath take care of yourself get
yourself
that means yourself and your health at
the same time yourself get quip and now
back to this
while died Italian did you ever start
did you do you feel like you always
liked it did you start to get scared
honestly like I noticed like in the past
couple of months I started to get like
some fear like am I supposed to be doing
something right now like when things
have started to pick up in the in the
entertainment internists be busier did
you have anything like that like what
was some of that like when you're like
wow is this just like excitement or is
this like my career is taking off like
you did you have like so many visceral
reactions to it I don't know what
visceral means either sounds like it's a
really powerful word I I learned to I
well no I I don't think it's yeah I
think it is fear I always live in fear
what I I'm always fearful but as far as
like doing other things it's like I
never wanted to spread myself then I
don't want to do stuff just to do it
right um I don't want to go on a show
where you know it's here for example
like a talking head shilling a Chelsea
Handler show type show I I don't like
doing those shows because I just know it
doesn't showcase me in a good way I
don't like vying for the attention of a
host or whatnot it's just not my style
of humor it's more a little bit late
back and kind of just comes and goes and
I'm not the guy who's like always on or
wants to get in so right yeah you're not
that guy yeah I just didn't I just
didn't want to do shows I'd have nothing
it's the show
it just doesn't showcase me in the right
way and I felt like when that was
happening I'm like oh man do I have to
be on the shows to sell tickets because
it seems like everybody that goes on
those types of shows was doing selling
out remember you have Fortune Josh wolf
all this guy yeah and you sit there and
go well no I'm just gonna stick to my
guns and I'll find another outlet or
I'll find my own way I just know that
that way for me is just it's not going
to showcase me well that's nice
sometimes I don't like doing podcasts
just because sometimes I feel like you
know
I gotta be funny or you know is this
something that people are gonna go oh I
don't know I don't know what's
interesting about me and I just I'm
sometimes I'm like why does someone want
to hear my story and yeah when I wrote a
book I'm like do I really did people
really want to read what I've been
through I felt like I didn't even have a
book in me have cancer and overcome it
or I didn't have like this big you know
get your sex traffic yeah there was
nothing that I liked I just came out
here 20 years ago to do stand-up and
there's been some some ups and downs
peaks and valleys but if people really
want to know that I don't know I
that's why I have a hard time with the
social media too it's like I look at
some of these guys and I geez man hey
they're up there every day yeah this is
hey I'm here I'm here I'm like I'm
struggling to get like one one post
every 72 hours ya know just because I'm
thinking in my head I go if people
really want to know that I'm yeah I'm
doing this so it's been desperate I
think you do it good though well I
really do I just I just try and if I do
something I just want it to be funny and
a lot of the stuff that I put up there I
this is what I do I film it I look at I
got this nobody wants to see this and I
erase it or my wife's in it she goes
hold on I got a look at it's like it's
it's a whole the whole thing a whole
ordeal so it's been that that's been a
kind of a struggle for me of how to how
to figure out the social media game yeah
where I where I'm in because I don't
have a lot of followers if you look at
my followers and then you look at the
people that come out to see my show
they really don't correlate you know
that's got to be interesting so then
that's not even where a lot of your
market is even at well you know it's an
older market it's a it's not a market
that's that's a younger eye skew kind of
older families parents whatnot although
I do have a lot of kids like twelve
thirteen year old kids that really enjoy
the facial expressions and what-have-you
but you know face Facebook is a place
where a lot of them live but you know
look at my Instagram and Twitter it's
it's relatively low numbers compared to
you know a lot of the people out there
that that have in the millions yeah and
no it's like ariana grande II yes 70 or
80 million and Pete Davidson
he started looked like her mood ring I
feel like whatever mood she's in that's
what color he dyes his hair you notice
like I see the guy up for different I
feel like it's red when it's that time
in a month - they die I don't that's a
bit much um could I have this is this
for me yeah it sure is mint buddy month
this is a new company but they're
they've been killing it but alright it's
like a it's like two calories or
something safe peach it's nice nice did
you think that um did your wife have to
talk you into fatherhood or was it
something that you wanted to do um put
it this way I was never a guy who wanted
kids like I was like 20 I'm like I can't
wait to have kids
but as I got older in life and a little
bit more secure my job and and and I was
stable started having a family was one
of my priorities and so glad I did it's
like one of those things you hear a time
and time again man I wish I would have
done this a little bit younger but
actually the timing of it all really
really worked out I mean it's it's it's
no I I was not talked into this that
wasn't talked into me I don't have this
relationship where it's like the woman
is like we gotta get married right it's
not like that and my wife is super super
opposite than me and that's why it works
and never pressures me to do anything
it's it's not that type of a
relationship but having a kid for for us
is man it's really something special
yeah and like what is it like what does
it brought out either you didn't know
cuz I mean I'm kind of fascinated by
that you know I'm scared like I get
scared about that kind of stuff I get
scared like I won't be able to you know
um like I'll mess up the relationship in
the family and then I won't be there for
Mike you know like I just get I don't
know I just kid I have a lot of fear I
guess about that kind of stuff did you
have any fears about it or just wasn't
something you're interesting no not
necessarily fears it was first of all
doing
the right woman mm-hmm I don't know how
the hell these people have kids and they
can't send their wife I don't know how
that even works yeah I mean you got to
love the person here with in order to
bring a child into this life because I'm
just my personal opinion looking at the
the trials and tribulations of parenting
if you're doing that with someone you
can't stand yeah does that suck so
Muffit out there some ladies in her car
all night eating chips and everything
and drinking big sodas breath [ __ ] that
dude this lady in our neighborhood brush
she used to say that she live by us but
she would just park out there and drink
big sodas in her car straight out of a
2-liter dude no strong nothing dumb
breath she was aggressive man it's used
to also deliver cookies for a while but
she got laid off from there anyway did
you close your eye like yeah we were
like reliving that I thought it was you
look like a singer are almost like
reliving that moment geez I've never
seen that someone close their eyes on
their own the Smokey Robinson of
[ __ ] let's bring in another video
question we got some great ones hello
Theo Sebastian and all this past weekend
listeners I am a dark arts enthusiast
from Turkey and I just freaking love
this podcast and I love both of you guys
but I just had a question for Sebastian
because I remember him talking about
being a shy guy growing up and was just
wondering how did he get out of shell
and decided to pursue comedy I would
just love to hear more about his
upbringing thank you yeah because you're
shy you're like who you're onstage
doesn't fit with who you are a hundred
percent like people probably expect you
to just [ __ ] just juggle in front of
them and [ __ ] their body or okay female
buddy you don't say no like people
expect this yeah no I'm I'm quite a I'm
like a loner I'm like a lone wolf
well I mean I I growing up I was never
the class clown I was always the quiet
kid I really really enjoyed getting up
in front of the class and doing a book
report or what have you because this is
what I just looked at people when they
went up in front of the class and it was
boring to me watching them yeah I'm like
come on man this is like we're here for
three hours give us something the guys
like I'm here for the Indian in the
cupboard he's in the back of the line I
wanted to be entertained right in in
school and I felt like I'm like wow he's
be felt like we was getting our money's
worth yes and I felt like I can't wait
to go up because I know I am really
gonna make these people laugh I not
necessarily read the book or anything
like that and I kind of masked my
inability to do the work with the humor
right and that's where I felt yeah
that's where I felt I could relate to
this yeah yeah so like you made people
laugh and maybe forgot why you were
there in the first place
that's kind of how I grew up and I
didn't I didn't really I wasn't the
popular kid I was kind of on the
outskirts I played soccer I didn't play
football I was I hung out with a bunch
of guys from another school so when I
free no man I was I've always been on
the outer perimeter of what's going on
well whatever's popular I'm always on
the outside kind of looking in and
that's been the story of my life I've
never been the popular guy I've always
kind of done my own little thing
and that's it so this question that this
this woman from Turkey has had asked it
was I feel more comfortable honest on a
stage talking to people than I do in
environments like this yeah because then
I tend to like edit myself I tend to be
a little bit more reserved I don't talk
off the cuff everything's kind of I
don't I get my head a lot one on one
there's like two or three people around
me
yeah I'm not I'm not I'm not like my fun
guy it's not who I am
but you got to admit that we need more
Mexican people in the NBA though you got
it the quota of Mexicans in the NBA is
low it's way too low I'm if you ever
seen Mexican guys play basketball it's
you know I haven't seen a lot wire is it
oh it's 30 on 30 with a soccer ball you
know that's a Jason Jason Killearn you
know he's a comedian yeah he's like yeah
and every shot is an 11 pointer but we
just need yeah I hear you man I mean I
think I feel you there it's like yeah
like uh well I think it makes sense if
you're on the outside then you can get a
perspective yeah maybe that's what it is
I never thought of it that way but I've
always been the guy kind of looking in
and never really part of the group there
were never part of any type of group but
do you want to be part of the group
don't sometimes yeah I wanted like why
like I'm like why am I not in that or
why am I not doing that this was early
on in my career right with work yeah
yeah but not necessarily with friends I
feel like I'm very comfortable of the
people in my life whether it be family
of friends and I've never really yearned
to be a part of a social group however I
do miss being part of a team um I played
team sports growing up there yeah missed
the camaraderie of going to hang it out
and busting balls and all that stuff
that that I do miss
but you know because comedy so lonely
yeah you know I'm saying I do miss a
group yeah and it's interesting and as
you get more famous um it's tougher to
get into a group almost because a little
bit you know what I'm saying like if
people know who you are it becomes you
know you feel like you have to almost
not check yourself but just make sure
that you're at a comfortable level you
know yeah I mean any any type of like
group activities and and and my wife and
I are kind of not struggling with this
but it's like we've moved into another
chapter in our life with having a baby
so now we are looking for people with
those shared experiences we're looking
for parents to kind of hang out with
right and you know with Sarafina my
daughter who is going into the preschool
another year we feel like we're going to
be introduced to a whole new group of
people
and which is going to be he doesn't say
much no but like I'm wanting that too
I'm wanting like I like that people over
that the house whether they new people
is fine I'm not saying I'm not going to
have any new friend right I'm just
saying it's kind of difficult at this
time and forget the career I'm just
saying to really find people that you
kind of mesh with yeah in my mid-40s you
know I'm saying it's like it's it's it's
a challenge yeah you won't just take
anybody like when I'm 11 or 12 I'll take
anybody asthma [ __ ] why don't you no
no arms you know what I'm saying
some [ __ ] turtleneck jockey or
whoever I'll take anybody some dude with
ants all over his body when you're like
seven years old you'll befriend anybody
some dude all bug collecting boogers on
his shoulder you know like no but it's
an adult it's like you so many things
you like you know not for me yeah I
think just over the years you kind of
like kind of know what you like and
don't don't like and yeah but it's gonna
be an exciting time now that my my
daughter's gonna be in the school we're
gonna be introduced to a whole different
group of people what's her first
Halloween car what's this Halloween
costume because I've picked out yet
working on last year she was a we
brought a big pot and yogi while she was
pasta oh I was like a little little it
was a hit there was a hit bro
and we were two chefs so we gotta top
that and we don't know yet my wife still
my wife super creative she's an ass
that's why I asked who did this ah and
and she's super creative I mean outside
the box creative it's a matter she
beautiful lady yeah we thank you we we
met you we talked to you this is about
five of maybe five six years ago at the
improv
and that's I think that's the first time
you met her yeah yeah you have a sister
- that almost came out or was gonna come
out to my show me own as a non
Chancellor but I canceled you canceled
on your sister bro but hey that's a
gentleman in your book probably you know
and he got it doesn't take your sister
did you ever reschedule it I did a
reschedule it it was okay it was good
out there you know I thought the service
was a little weird at the club but I
thought everything else was good you who
told me a good story the other day oh
Stanhope did some shows hair he had
Johnny Depp come out to watch him oh wow
at the Oxnard improv they just put a
chair off to the side in the crowd but
off to the side Johnny Depp sat there
the whole time watched him then they
went in the groom and stayed in there
all night just drinking and smoking
cigarettes until the crowd know he was
there but towards the end people started
to know wow so much alike when half the
staring
Tim Burton's little side piece you know
a vetted got interesting what was it
what was a Halloween like when you were
a kid you remember it he yeah I was um
one outfit was the Hulk I remember it
was the Hulk Hulk pajamas but my wife
put a snowstorm I wife my mom put a snow
suit on me and then put the pajamas over
the snow suit and that was one of the
other that's a good idea
and then another one was rocky I was
rocky and how many kids were rocky there
a lot
but I had like a really bad rocky outfit
I had a rocky kind of taped with medical
tape to the back of the world a lot of
the outfits would not not like high end
yeah at all it was it was like piecemeal
oh yeah we had a guy who just drew a
swastika on his back one time
didn't hear me oh there we go to go home
uh-oh
this is a Chinese family really adorable
oh that's so cute when you look at your
daughter now can you remember her being
like yeah yeah yeah I mean she is small
I'm looking at her now wow she's really
grown but yeah that seems like it was
yesterday but yeah man it's great and
you have a little baby like this and
you're doing these things and seeing the
smile on her face and she's talking now
she's just starting to walk it's it's
really cool you got to go on right I'm
thinking about it man I want to get my
sperm tested somewhere though you know
they do all this other stuff where you
can get everything to I just you want to
get the sperm tested to make sure you
know that I'm that you know that you
could have a baby yeah that kind of a
baby you know so you're just you have a
girlfriend yeah I got a girlfriend um
and seeing this white girl she's good an
adult but these days look that's a good
qualification exam all right and an
adult oh yeah I mean I would go in any
eraser I don't they're not no not gender
yeah I go any race or ethnicity but yeah
this she's white adult you know but
we'll see you know we're figuring it out
man you know I I struggle with that kind
of stuff I've always troubled with
commitment you know you never really had
a long-term study know I've always been
uncommitted in relationships I think
I've been uncommitted in my mothership
with myself even when I really think
about it like in my own life you know
like a we'll see if this takes you know
well how old are you 38 okay
yeah man I think I think this is good
for you maybe um maybe you settle down
with the white girl no well it could be
look it could happen you don't know what
was the number one thing like is it like
cuz you see a lot of people that are
real fuck-buddies out there and then
next thing you know they're broken up by
you know by Thanksgiving you know a lot
of these things you know relationships
these days it doesn't even seem to be
able to some a lot of kids are doing
seems illegal almost another couple
months in America that should be equal
to even you're right man
compared to when I was single with all
these apps and what-have-you it just
seems like you know people are swiping
meat and you know they screw on the
sidewalk and then they go on to the next
guy yeah girl it's uh it seems like it
seems frightening actually what's going
on out there I don't even know I think
how the hell people are doing it it's a
bit out of the dating scene for ten
years so I don't even know how I would
even fit into that yeah they give a go
to kind of date that you used to do back
in the day or anything um I love dating
I love you because I love the
hospitality of it a date I love the
actual everything you're gonna end up
working at the pearly gates who's the
guy they got there now st. Peter you're
gonna you're gonna you're gonna give
that guy
we got a 4-time just hold on no I loved
going and picking the girl up yeah
getting in the car surprising her with a
little place though some music now would
you put music on the car in the car I'm
not a not a music guy in the car I'm not
really a music guy ya know but I love
going like she'd go where we don't
Ananas it's a little surprise you know I
never never really told her look I'd
like I'd find that um it's a place in
Chicago called pops for champagne I
remember taking a girl's in like
nineteen and they're downtown to the
city like a lot of other guys were just
like hey come over let's go and to the
movies I'd go on the the expressway
30-minute drive pull up pops for
champagne that a fake ID sit down watch
a little jazz like I just love the
experience of the actual date yeah going
out and showing a girl a good time and
and yeah that's that's kind of that was
my go-to that's what I loved loved to do
I could see that the serve the interest
that service industry you know I'm
trying to think of a good date I took a
girl on one time I think there was some
man I don't know I definitely got a I
was always running around like what's it
like what's your idea like like you're
gonna get to know a girl what do you
don't like hey let's go for caught like
what's the what are you doing probably
go for a like a walk like a local walk
probably do I don't know I don't like it
I don't know if I like getting to know
people that much you know so I think
probably some mmm a local walk
what is that as opposed to we're like
going somewhere like getting lost I
guess like I can get an adventurous if I
don't have aa you know run clothes and I
go for a like a nine mile walk in one
direction bruh that's really dangerous
but so do you like
that's a good question man do you like
food I mean you like trying new foods to
found nothing under that you know it's
funny when you said music I never really
got into music that much a lot of people
from your area I know a lot out of those
guys are in like you know wrestling in
their backyards and [ __ ] like that and
like um who is that Bruce Springsteen
probably huh my area yeah wrestling in
yards yeah I feel like Chicago it's like
a place where people wrestling about
like you backyard wrestling and Bruce
Springsteen we didn't we didn't do it we
didn't I promise cotton we had a lot of
that oh there you go baby up north of
Wisconsin a little off base they were
diving off the roof
my mother's from Peoria actually okay is
that where you picked up that Chicago's
is wrestling mecca about a bad Intel I
grew up in Arlington Heights there was
not a lot of wrestling I I was into
wrestling yeah any weren't doing it
let's get her one of these and we got a
voicemail this one on your special why
did you do that
I wonder if he can just be
- that crazy house that you were wearing
income of your thought process behind it
Thanks you are a master of ceremony you
are what's the one you look like a kind
of like a maitre d on here MA
was that it that was things that was a
vest but the van oh yeah I saw that was
built in to the shirt oh yeah you don't
see that too often this is my this is my
whole deal with the outfits sometimes I
feel like if you wear something a little
bit off the beaten path and people are
switching channels it catches their eye
you know even if you were just scrolling
you'd see that and go with them what the
hell is this guy wearing yeah and they
would point they would maybe just stop
that's kind of my plus I thought it was
you know it kind of fit what I was doing
for that particular special I'm always
doing something a little different I had
like black and white spats shoes on for
that I don't know it's for me it's just
good point not being not being so
ordinary I guess talk about
entertainment like you you know trying
to be you know just entertain people not
only with the material and the
physicality of it all but also with the
outfit and a lot of I got a lot of [ __ ]
for that say what the hell you wearing
what do you yeah a penguin or to use
waiting tables or whatnot
you know if people say what they want to
say that's fine that they've got their
own opinion but I just I just wanted to
be a little bit off the beaten path yeah
it's like the WWE meets kind of Tony
Romo and I'm just joking uh I mean and I
appreciate you let me even make fun of
you dude believe me I got my eye I grew
up in a family and friends rip each
other to shreds so I'm not was there
some moments when it was weird to you
walk back into your family and you're
becoming a star you know and you know in
it and I don't call you that because I
feel like you expect me to call you that
you know I call you that a star because
you know you've earned it and you've
worked your way so hard and that you
know like you're gonna be known as that
but was there a moment you go back into
your house when you almost sound like
you have to keep your ego in check but
you got to just kind of make sure you
know where you are a little
because your ego is this thing that can
kind of grow inside he won't be like a
real dirty bullet you know I've never
really been thought of it my family
keeps me so like level-headed that I've
never even thought well um you know
doing well or I'm a star whatever I
never even enters my mind my sister my
mother my father my wife they you know
they joke it's all a joke it's it's even
if I did say something that would be a
little bit more like like I was acting
as I started I go we big shine now so
it's it's all like in fun and there's
never been a moment where I had actually
had to check myself because there's no
really try I mean I'm just a guy doing
stand-up comedy that happens that a lot
of people come out and see me do what I
do so right nothing's really changed for
me with my relationships so you don't
have to yeah okay so you weren't
thinking I'm like oh they're gonna look
at me different or they're gonna think
of me different no they're very proud
they're very excited they they they've
been there from day one they know the
journey they know the you know all the
the failures I've gone through as well
as the successes so they know it they
know it inside and out and I've never
had to stop and think otherwise hmm it's
interesting yeah I guess maybe it's a
moan how there's no my family like have
him you know we've always been like such
fighters and stuff and angry and like
like I remember nobody had fun of miles
unless somebody was crying bro oh really
and if somebody was eating a piece of
meat you get him to cry bro it's hard to
swallow meat and cry at the same time
because your throats trying to work both
ways yeah that is a tough deal Oh crying
they need meat I never even really heard
of that oh be some bad skirt steak in
your throat son and you start tearing up
bro you if I can get lost it fit a
bridge to terabithia your throat what
else you got here another voice okay hey
what's up Theo this is a question for
Sebastian I was just curious who is his
comedy influences starting in his career
30 comedy influences I grew up watching
Three's Company John Ritter was a huge
influence on me
noises off have you seen that
No some movie he was it's really really
neat no I haven't seen that but his his
depiction of John Ritter with the
physical comedy was always I learned a
lot in watching him I mean I'd watched
Three's Company like game tape you know
I I would just look at his he could just
do a movement with his head and you
would just know how he was feeling it
was all a lot of facial and pratfalls
and physicality there's one episode it
really sticks out when he was trying to
sit on a hammock and the hammock conflit
over and the way he would flip over and
look surprised it was just really really
brilliant stuff so him Johnny Carson I
always loved the Brian Regan Jerry
Seinfeld George Carlin Robin the Eddie
Murphy days yeah Dice Clay i-i've looked
at his career and just talking about a
spectacle and making a show a show I
opened up for him for two years so the
way he would you know and we've had
talks about this offstage he would say
you know that's entertainment it's it's
it's larger than life and and you know
and that's gonna kind of learn just just
taught talking to a lot of different
people and their process so yeah that's
where the influence is growing up and
Michael Jackson maybe Michael Jackson I
wasn't kind of talk about spectacle his
just his quick movements sometimes is a
surprise to the audience and I've
incorporated that to just where you're
telling a joke and you know the audience
is there with you and then you bust out
into a physical move it's unexpected it
takes them off-guard
in this day and age to when everybody's
attention being so fragmented I mean I
like I got to give these people a show
not only verbally but physically and it
keeps some people on their toes you can
see they're like they're almost like
waiting for it yeah waiting for like a
jolt or whatever Michael Jackson
watching him not only in his stage show
to which now I'm kind of as I'm doing
Minuteman theater should mute is that
one of the ones that you and enjoyed
watching me you told me about it I
remember has he one time for like advice
you're like michael jackson munich
munich munich germany and
that's all he said that's all he said
Budapest was also a good one but his
stage and and and light show which now
I'm also looking at is I am bringing in
production for the show you know large
screen like a lot of what I do is in my
face and you can't see it if you're in
the Baja so I brought in a large LED
wall behind me where people now in the
entire theater and when we do arenas we
do it in the round and we put a big
screen above me where you could see it
all and the lights I'm in - how do you
light the audience how do you like the
stage do you like the stage when you're
doing arena do you do put a like a laser
light around the stage to outline it all
these different things I'm totally into
and that's what I watching Michael
Jackson in the stage show and seeing his
bad tour when I was back in Chicago in
19 I think 85 or 90 will forget what it
was but I just was fascinated about the
spectacle of the show yeah
it's at the end of the day you got to
make people laugh right right that's
whether they're four right are they
gonna notice that oh my god he's got
lights on this it they're not but it's
almost like it it's you and you walk in
you create an environment for people and
it's expected and if you don't have it I
think it's it's noticeable man it's
interesting how the hospitality is such
a thing in your life you know like you
do want to give them something you want
to give them some you don't just want to
take yeah they're paying a high ticket
price yeah so you you want to give them
the enjoyment of going out and enjoying
an experience rather than just a
microphone and a curtain yeah and that's
fine if you're doing that but for me
being in that hospitality mindset I just
want to give people a lot of options you
come to my house I'm not just doing
burgers right doing burgers Italian
sausage I'm doing you know I'm gonna
have a little steak on the side I put
out a plethora of different things for
people to enjoy and it's always been in
my head
I mean it's it's transferred into my
career started it started just me
knowing the ins and out of hospitality
working for the Four Seasons Oh time
right and anticipating people's
expectations and that's kind of what I'm
doing in my shows I'm trying to
anticipate what people are wanting when
they come out for an evening of comedy
do you think that do you have like an
ideal show past the ones you've done I
mean is it scary to go out into like an
arena and and like Metascore guard is
scary to go out in these places and and
have and feel like you're still doing
comedy and no I don't feel that at all I
feel like oh this is just a bigger
setting there's more pressure in the
sense that you know doing a Madison
Square Garden and it's kind of the
epicenter of New York City and the
world's famous arena so yeah there is
definitely an added pressure but I feel
like wow now I could really start
entertaining yeah Wow really start
showcasing what I do not that you have
to be in an arena to do that but it
brings a level of excitement that just
isn't there and maybe a comedy club yeah
a comedy club is great I love comedy
clubs but you know this it's just it's
just another level of excitement for me
you dreams were an arena as it sounds
like no really I didn't want the I came
with your setting of your dreams like
you were thinking about a Michael
Jackson or something like that you're
like you know that are you know not that
you're looking for that but it's in the
back of my head no but if you see if
Michael jack he's in an arena it's like
you know it's there's something else in
that environment you know yeah yeah I
had it I had it in me like if I ever got
to a situation where I had to bring in
lighting or bring in sound or what have
you that that's the way I would want to
do it but ultimately I mean I came out
to LA in 1998 and my goal was to do
stand-up comedy for a living that's it
that there wasn't there was nothing else
in the thing there was no sitcom
movie I didn't want to do any of that I
just want I want to make people laugh
and I want to get paid for it that's it
and you know it's growing a little bit
past that but I was always kind of
prepared of what I kind of wanted if I
ever did get there of how I wanted it to
look aesthetics is big with me yeah
Jesus you have it it's the most insane
interior designer
no I'll tell you it's my wife though -
really well here I mean look at you you
could just have this place as a you know
gray walls and that's it right but you
bring in you know this you bring in the
painting you bring in the mural you know
there's a lot of extra things here that
you bring in to make the environment
what it is yeah and and you got a point
and get plants in there yeah and one of
these I think if that one's an
endangered species actually I think just
came out on I got an email the other day
actually I don't if we can have that
anymore California they're recalling
everything it's living and they say that
that plant sexually abused another plane
[Laughter]
don't put it near female plants let's
take another question I want to get
through a couple more of these because I
know that our listeners are so excited
yo-yo was good this is Ron from Los
Angeles someone asked if Sebastian I
want to ask about his time with Andrew
Dice Clay I know he toured with him for
a little bit just curious to see if he
was inspired by dice and if so how and
also if he hasn't he just kind of crazy
stories about being on the road with the
dice man
much love yeah I dedicated a chapter in
my book to going on the road with Dice
Clay so when you were opening Fermi's at
the top I was opening for him when he
was primarily working Las Vegas at the
Stardust Hotel in the Wayne Newton
theater so I was the first time I've
actually ever done Vegas was with dice
and the room was just a throwback to old
Vegas black and cushions you know like
kind of like those half moon couches
yeah like at The Comedy Store kinda yeah
yeah
and kind of teared really really nice
and yeah he what I learned from dice is
the spectacle of entertainment
is being kind of more than just a guy
that goes out there that's in front of a
microphone again nothing wrong with that
but I'm like I'd love that whole kind of
larger than life experience so yeah
that's that's kind of what I learned
from from the Diceman and do fans love
that too you think it's interesting you
say this cuz I talked with some of this
sometimes like like I want to be
authentic but you know we all we want to
be as a relatable as Clark Kent but we
want also want to be we all want to put
on a [ __ ] cape sometimes excitement I
guess that's what I would explain it to
I'm talking about everyday things in my
act I'm talking about the relationship
with my father the relationship with my
wife the birthday party that we threw
for my daughter
all these different things but doing it
in a way where you know it you feel like
you're watching a show yeah I mean
that's that's it you could still be
authentic and still be real but you
could also still give people a show and
to your point in the beginning of this
this conversation was gives people an
entertaining environment which they feel
like they are at something that is
really special right it's a man I just I
love see an entertainment entertainment
deserves a big show like I have a dream
somewhere in my head of running across
the stage and sliding on my knees across
the stage I don't know for what hey
sounds good to me man I was lovely to go
fun to go through a through a slide on
his knees I can hit hit a light on the
stage let's get a little more here hey
studio big fan both of you guys you and
Sebastian I just wanted to say talk
about the if you can talk about
malocchio again
my grandpa was a Greek man and my
grandma's Spanish and they both have
similar I knew my grandma used to cover
your face and gargle with salt water and
spit on your forehead to get rid of it
yeah yeah if you can delve more into
that is basically where he goes with it
the enemy's facelift want to do that
he's talking and referring to the evil
eye and it
culture someone might put like a curse
on you and they'll give you the evil eye
and they'll say something and then you
have like bad luck coming your way
voodoo yeah it's like voodoo and there's
ways to combat this in the Italian
culture one of the ways is having an
Italian if you see those horns took a
red horn hanging off your rear view
mirror near your car kind of protecting
you from any outside influence also
there's a thing it's a it's a keychain
and it's a hand that's like this and you
attach it to you how hard is it there
are so many rules but all these things
kind of combat this evil eye and in
different cultures into this guy's point
with the Greeks yeah I see there it is
you put that on your keychain and that's
supposed to really kind of keep the evil
spirits away it looks like something
from Dane Cook's gift shop they probably
got this on some deal yeah I think about
it but this is like the way I grew up
right there's a horseshoe here's another
one
there's a horseshoe that you have to so
this demon doesn't come into your house
oh yeah you put a horseshoe and you flip
it upside down you got to put it over
the door and this again combats any type
of any of the Wow yeah it's it's a lot
so every culture has their own thing
yeah Greek Spanish what have you it's
superstition yeah huh they don't have
that in a Nicaraguan culture daily I
don't know what we had man my dad was so
old when I was growing up we used to
have I'm trying to think you had an
older father yeah my never 70 when I was
woman I was born in 1910 so yeah my dad
was just oldest heck man when I think he
was cool bruh but he had like big you
know blood kind of spots on his skin
it's like I had just weird influences
growing up like I remember like drawing
like you know you get those liver spots
on your skin cuz your livers trying to
get out of your body cuz it's sick of
living with you once you get so old and
I would draw those
my arm and stuff so I'll be at school
just like trying to look like my dad you
know eivol like his liver spots drawing
them just weird [ __ ] I mean it was fun
though - you know he was always joking
around dude he bought a delta a Cutlass
from somebody write a couple of brothers
that lived a couple blocks over he
bought a Cutlass from him and it had
speakers in her probably like 20 this
back when speakers matter more than
anything
20 40 inches who gave a damn you know
and it had bass from my dad he was so he
can hear it or feel any of it he just
got the car he didn't care about the
speakers right so he'd be listening like
Paul Harvey or NPR just bass the [ __ ]
out you know like Paul Paul you know
just like listen to the weather report
of just absolutely ridiculous so just
that was kind of my world I grew up
there was like nothing mattered you know
like or like any and nothing was
off-limits to joke about you know my
brother would come in and be like dad's
dead nobody keep [ __ ] better not be
dead dude or he better be dead i'ma whup
your ass you know like just the weirdest
you know we take weird angles and stuff
and communication is a different
upbringing but yeah he was off my dad
was from Nicaragua and then he so he
talked he spoke a bunch of Spanish but
he ain't really teach us anything you
know um so I don't know he would talk in
Spanish he would flirt with some ladies
over there he let me go skip school and
go sit at the bar with him and eat
Hershey Kisses up there
I could eat 80 Hershey Kisses bro I'll
put down two bags brah
wake up later in the backseat of that
[ __ ] Thunderbird nothing wild it
happened but just you know sugar in
terror but anyway that's kind of a
boring story let's take one more and
we'll get out of here one more yo Theo
yo Sebastian it's Eric from Vancouver
Canada
Sebastian I know you are very Italian my
girlfriend's Italian I'm gonna meet her
whole Italian family at a family reunion
next week just wonder if you got any
advice for me advice in Italian reunion
chew with your mouth closed I'm gonna
give him that advice rigged I was kind
of just polishing off a sandwich there
and decided to make the video yeah and
his phone look dirty clean you're not
bro you've been eatin caramels or
something clean your phone off yeah
before you go to the reunion give your
phone a nice wipe down and and nothing I
mean the just enjoy enjoy it there's
gonna be it's gonna be loud and it's
gonna be a lot of food hopefully and a
lot of horseshoes so um yeah just enjoy
yourself and and stop eating
why are you do videos yeah tighten up do
you have a family um I was gonna ask one
uh so I oughta do you do you still are
you still friends with dice you guys
still closer no I haven't thought the
dice I haven't got the dice in a while I
think the last time I saw dice clay was
in the parking lot at the comedy store
maybe two years ago yeah he XSL
makehuman he's very I thought he's very
mean I'd never worked with him or
anything but he was he just seemed like
he was very too cool for school to the
point where it wasn't cool it was like
we can't be too cool for maybe he can't
be too cool for everything you know like
he was too cool to even act like we were
working on the same show at all that he
brought me on stage he kept [ __ ] my
name up I like on purpose at a certain
point where it was just like you know so
I got up there I was like give it up you
guys give it up for Andrew you know I
don't know if that's his real name or
not or Andy I don't know what I called
him or drew something but anyway maybe
that's my maybe I've my own resentment
and I don't know why I think I did oh
sorry you had that experience no worries
is it hard to be uh do you find Cuddy
you find that comments the Brotherhood
is pretty good overall the Brotherhood
of comedians yeah um yeah I think it is
I mean again actually I listen to Joe
Rogan talked about this with Bert
Kreischer and Tom Segura yesterday on
his podcast saying that now more than
that
the camaraderie amongst comedians is is
fantastic I mean everybody's happy for
one another or maybe in the past that
wasn't the case people would be like
jealous
like I why'd he get that why'd she get
that or what have you I mean that's that
element is still there but you see a lot
of comedians now kind of like hanging
out and and in doing it together rather
than doing it on their own and I think
you're part of that like group of guys
the fighter and the kid and then the
Rogen's and the crisis and the Segura's
seem to be all like bodies and you know
one goes on one show another and yeah
real supportive supportive and it's
great you know like some somebody's
Netflix special comes out everybody
posts a watch Bert watch Theo watch this
watch that so yeah I think it's really
really great for myself I just you know
being on the outside and I've never
really been a part of any comedic clique
you know I come up I came up with a few
guys in the late 90s like the Bret Ernst
of the world yeah meds the kappa rule
those were kind of Steve Byrne yeah all
in our kind of class it was like a class
at The Comedy Store like everybody got
past and they kind of went up together
but other than that but you're always on
the perimeter a little bit you always
are just the same just perceiving kind
of yeah cuz you do seem like you don't
seem like you guys that's rude or
anything but you seem like a guy that's
Mia maybe just kind of I don't fit
scarred to get to know ya I am I create
a very very tough shell it's it's I
don't let a lot of people in but when I
do you're a friend for life Wow
and and and I don't know again that's I
think by I don't know exactly what the
mechanism is but I've always been a
little bit standoffish with people and
it could come off as abrasive rude or
aloof but it's a little bit more of the
fact that I am deep down a shy guy mmm
and don't like to expose myself a lot I
don't like to talk a lot it's it's not
something I enjoy
doing wow you're a strangest dude you
are the strangest - you've been
endangered species man you probably
hoofed the rest you left the earth a
long time ago you're still out here
milling around they're all up in heaven
like how is this mahogany this guy I'll
survive out here you don't talk to mow
no Ivy are you going on I mean I don't
know I mean again I'm not opposed to I'm
not opposed to having friendships no
doesn't seem like it but you know I for
whatever the reason always felt like it
was hard for me to fit in yeah that's
that's the main thing do you feel like
it was hard for you to do so or do you
feel like people didn't accept you in I
think a lot of it's in my head
right I think I'm talking a lot in my
head going this guy's like yeah so I
think I talked myself out of a lot of
things and actually my wife has helped
me with being a lot more accepting and
open to other people because she's that
way she's from Memphis Tennessee she was
the south she's happy she's come on like
the more the merrier
and she's kind of opened that side of me
that I never really had growing up or in
my early adulthood so she's been a huge
influence of you know opening our house
and come on in like she's the type of
like that stay with us for the weekend
and I'm right can't you yeah no you know
like that's that's that's the dynamic
but I've learned a lot learned a lot in
the last 10 years from her that's cool
man let's take uh let's take one last
call under he wanted to put it in here
we're getting pretty slim pickings but
this took a just a crack me up okay just
wanted to know when you come into
Australia hey let's get organized Wow
you know he that's in line for my
podcast actually uh sighs it must be a
podcast listener what is the pressure
what is it with Austrians always want
Mystica that's all they ever ask
to be winning income income because
they're in the middle of nowhere didn't
need any company um
Australia I am coming to 2019 we don't
know when I went there I think was a
year and a half ago two years ago and I
had a great time there my wife and I and
we're definitely wanting to go back it's
just the scheduling hasn't opened up
enough time to kind of go and do that
but 2019 I have a really really good fan
base there a lot of Italians and
probably 2019 yeah
do you see yourself doing like um you
know like I know you've worked in some
television and film like is that
something that you've that you're still
like is it feel like an aim I feel like
these days the power feels like it's in
the stand-up more than anything these
days it's just in the actual stage show
yes it is
yeah I've been doing a couple movies
here and there but I like doing serious
movies I don't like not that don't like
doing comedy I like exercising a more
serious muscle because I'm like a
serious guy yeah and I like to do more
of a dramatic type of movie there's one
coming out this November 21st called the
Green Book which is a really really good
movie and I've really enjoyed working
with like some some serious actors you
know so it's a nice departure from the
stand-up yeah I plan on doing more of it
but you're right I think you know the
bread and butter so as the stand-up
that's that's where that's where it is
at least for me yeah do you feel like
like what would you have an ideal kind
of role like a Maitre D' that [ __ ]
you know ghosty you know I'm like a
James Bond sort of a Maitre D' that that
maybe I don't know like when I was
working at the Four Seasons I always
look at people that I didn't
particularly like waiting on and maybe
something there they make her next and
major day I could see that that's a good
one I mean yeah like room service maybe
they didn't tip and then later on when
they're in the parking lot there's the
fifth season with Sebastian Maniscalco
man I feel this is the most this is a
guest have a moat most excited to have
me we've had some really great guests in
here and um but yeah dude I mean I just
I know it's hard to like get to know you
and you know like you know because
uterus are kind of like kind of keep to
yourself a little bit but it's not
because you're a mean guy anything no no
I mean again like we have parties at the
house and and you know it's just like I
don't know I don't really have a lot of
people's like I've known you for what 15
years I don't even think I can I see him
all the time at the cavity store he was
in where the hell were you at the
Brugada right before you're gonna
Orleans I remember I was doing the
little I was doing some dump truck
outside I was performing in right a9
seat truck that had been hollowed out
and I walk in and there he's in the back
making wine he's got an open or some guy
some guy dude Joe somebody he's got his
shoes off and he's got on uh they're
playing that I Love Lucy in the
background and a Joe's making wine with
his feet in there for Sebastian
tested her from the side with a spoon
like ratatouille - bitter Joe keep
moving on but it was this big room and I
even just went on stage and it's looked
out of like wow this is fascinating yeah
so all this the years I've known you I
can never exchange information although
I don't even know if people are doing
that anymore I mean like if I want to
get ahold you and I hit you up I like
the message or an Instagram now I don't
even know how it works yeah this guy's
lover I just walked in he's sitting
there like on a throne waiting for me to
walk in we lit two cables even though
it's illegal in the air no I'm gonna
normally do this no the guy at the front
man he'll shut it down
it's like an RA at a dorm at a Catholic
dorm dude you don't care if there's dead
bodies is there a candle lit [ __ ]
shut yeah and yeah well thank you so
much for coming man and congratulations
on all your success dude and thanks for
leading the way for for entertainers man
it makes me I think it's gonna make a
lot of young guys wanna get on stage I
wanna be
Tanner's who haven't seen it in a long
time well thanks man I am just I'm just
that's very nice of you to say thank you
yeah you bet Sebastian Maniscalco ladies
and gentlemen
[Music]
little time for me to set that parking
brake
[Music]
Wow you know what's crazy as my sister
can't even read it but what does it have
to do with us right now hope you enjoyed
that video and you can watch another and
you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices some guy just brings you one
option not this guy two options watch
one this one or this one